a 1276 Haley Graham Andrew Liberal
Democrats 1687 Lenny
David Labour Party 40,000 Rumble
Patricia and UK Independence Party you
Kip
462 Stacy miles the Conservative Party
candidate 5665 topamax past forty nine
thousand three hundred and thirty nine
the total number of ballot papers
rejected was 147 and I do hereby declare
that the said David Lammy is duly
elected member of parliament cotton
hello an elephant like a you detective
David learning to say a few words but
look I begin by thanking the returning
officer with Avery let here the last
American gay also thanking cluing the
marine in countless stuff for all work
yeah they've done over the course of
today I also thank my agent for the
fantastic work that he has done Josh and
also Jack in my office and it would be
remiss of me if I didn't think Avery led
by Sima and the whole of the Tottenham
constituency Labour Party thank you for
all of your work not just supporting
Lena Tottenham but going all around the
country supporting labour candidates
this is my 17th year as the Member of
Parliament for Tottenham and is really
quite humbling to at this point in the
election cycle to be standing here with
the biggest majority and MP for topic
has ever had thank you I could never
have anticipated having over an 80
percent share of the vote and that is
down to the hard work of the Labour
Party here in Tottenham London borough
of Haringey I thank you from the bottom
of my heart tonight result in top and
reflects a result in the country we are
seeing a massive turnout we are seeing
young people registered and voting we
are seeing people rejecting the
austerity that we've experienced in this
country for seven years and here in the
London borough of Haringey we are
communicating proudly that we wish to
remain in the European
[Applause]
tonight's set of results is a disaster
for Theresa May and I'm quite sure she
is considering her position this was the
lecture that we did not need how now ten
days before we go into negotiations with
the European human she goes now into a
position where she is weaker today and
she was seven weeks ago and that is down
to a minimal campaign by one of the best
campaigning and beats over the last
thirty years in the United Kingdom and
that is Jeremy quarantine we are not
surprised that my dear neighbor Jeremy
Corbyn has led the Labour Party to this
set of results tonight
now there's still ups and more results
to come in came with what we now see is
that those who predictable weapons that
we would be losing since in the north of
England our brand with NDP our facials
in stuff let's see where we get to by
the end of the evening but this is a
mode all revived for the UK Labour Party
I thank you here again from the bottom
of my heart it is a privilege to serve
the community that I had lived in that I
was born in where I will owe people deep
in my heart and I look forward very
shortly to more powerful results in my
neighbouring consistent constituency
enhancing camera great thank you very
much
[Applause]